john please handle the intro ladies and
gentlemen it's time for brooklyn nine
nine season one episode 19 yeah we're
gonna check this out what's the title
it's the tactical village but first hey
guys if you like this video if you like
brooklyn nine-nine be sure to hit the
like button below this video as well as
the subscribe button really helps us out
in the youtube algorithm also if you
want to watch the full version of this
episode sync up with your own copy come
on over to our patreon page we got a ton
of shows there were at the same tier you
get reaction highlights plus watch
alongs last but not least for thumb
gentle thank you for editing these
highlights down ah let's get in doyle's
door on the intro
did i do it yeah he didn't look at me
the whole time
[Music]
for you
and you
and you what are these these madame are
stds
stds
save the dates
i've gotten a lot of those lately oh
okay i get it std has another meaning
that you're gross will you be serving
crabs at the reception give her guys
this is my wedding this is important to
me you're right and we're sorry yes we
love you buddy warts and all sorry i
made a rash decision
i have an std
[Laughter]
so just rsvp or yeah the number's right
on the answers great
you shouldn't expect nothing less should
have made that tea lowercase
and not solve the problem that's a solid
cold open people absolute there's so
many italian people who star in this
show
like andre brauer
happy tactical village day it's the most
fun day of the year something you
wouldn't understand because you're not
programmed to feel joy yes but my
software is due for an exuberance
upgrade you know when you play along
with robot jokes it kind of ruins my
enjoyment of them yes i know that's the
point it's also a good opportunity for
us to let off steam and bond as a unit
everybody gets into it
oh yeah remember those paint grenades
but jake has been the finalist for
coolest kill two years in a row that's
every precinct sending around their
footage and all the cops voting it's not
that big of a deal all you win is a
children's karate trophy so
you desperately want it don't you so
badly who would have wanted karate
gina
gina
sorry i was playing crazy cupcakes crazy
cupcakes okay how you play you just line
up three cupcakes with the same color
frosting
stop playing this in name garbage it's
embarrassing say it to my face he's
gonna get into it tell me how i'm any
different than george clooney he has a
sexy voice i have a sexy voice champagne
mountain range mountain range i couldn't
think of anything sexy to say mountain
range it's the sexiest geological
feature no wait sorry deep sea trench
oh ooh
you try to think of some sexier words
jesuit
what is going on with you two come on
boyle not this again you gotta admit
there's a spark how many times do i have
to say it she's like a sister that's
what luke said about leia hey luke
didn't know no one knew
[Laughter]
boyle said a date already he gave out
save the days yesterday i think he's
been avoiding me
no
oh i hate what
i hate pizza
maybe vivian was uncomfortable with you
coming look boy i was in love with you
until a few weeks ago
oh no
i'm not angry i think it's funny
so creepy
hey
what you doing in here nothing okay cool
can i just see your bro i i may have
been playing crazy cupcakes okay captain
i think we're past the point of you
being too proud to say the w
i play so much that when i close my eyes
at night i just see cupcakes now well i
have a tremendous amount of self-control
as a matter of fact i've deleted
the application there does this mean
i've lost my progress
well it doesn't matter
[Laughter]
amy santiago
teddy oh my gosh oh [ __ ] it's been so
long what are you doing here i'm with
the 8-2 now we're paired with you today
yeah quick ambulance case severed limb
what is going on here oh no
well i'm gonna go sign in but we should
catch up later yeah great seeing you you
too i hate that guy
that was teddy we went on like five
dates last year i liked him but he was
stationed out in queens so i never got
to see him and sort of fizzled right
that's the guy you said the lame stuff
about like he's a good listener
do you look for in a guy i don't know
real stuff
shape of his ass
it's so weird that amy dated that guy
why do you care so much
it's creepy and second i don't care i'm
just curious why she would like him
whatever you say
yeah i sound like meryl streep and mama
yeah exactly
[Laughter]
oh this is so cool shoot around corners
i had a nerf gun like that
not even going to touch that the amy
santiago story
[Music]
hey i got one how about 10.69 that's
easy message received and simultaneously
given am i right up top
69.
got it yeah so they got the new handguns
in you wanna check them out totally
worse
i thought he was talking to me annie
clearly was chop chop ted let's roll
pull down the port
oh
oh
it emits a focused beam of sound which
can disorient and even incapacitate a
perk is this a trigger yes but you want
to be careful with that ah
i thought it would be louder it's highly
directional if we're pointed at you
you'd be incredible pain right now
[Music]
no
i can take my thoughts enough the ass oh
my god
that's [ __ ] up man
have you seen captain holt tall handsome
gentleman dressed like an airline pilot
your pants are up i'm coming in
captain i think you might have a little
bit of a problem here boo i have this
under control you should leave this is a
men's room
[Laughter]
a liar's dead
if i want to play crazy cupcakes i will
play crazy cupcakes
crazy is a difficult word to say in
anger but i think i've made my feelings
clear have you noticed they moved the
trigger real exciting finger feel
nice two to the chest textbook shooting
yeah and his overalls fell down i can't
believe you would kill a farmer the
backbone of our nation's economy
when it comes to shooting patterns i
like to go pb and j penis brain jaw
oh
good shots penis is an effective target
interesting fact a man can run half a
mile with no genitals that's a weird
thing to know a lot about
shooting him with that sonic cannon was
an accident
it's not just that
[Music]
oh no
sorry miss fire
oh
ride my breath
talk to him that's what friends do nope
i'm gonna wait till i'm on my deathbed
get in the last word and then die
immediately that's your plan for dealing
with this that's my plan for dealing
with everything i have 77 arguments i'm
gonna win
oh this is gonna be awesome
i'm working on a thing where when i'm
out of ammo i release my mag and
dropkick gets straight into someone's
throat
oh
my buttholes
oh you have two bullet wounds in your
butt but you gotta stop calling them
your buttholes
a course record that is so cool oh
thanks i'm psyched hey good luck in
there thanks all right god damn it i
hate that guy all right on three let's
break that course record and be the best
precinct here ready one two three
[Laughter]
that's what i'm talking about man
a group of armed men entered an embassy
and have taken hostages which embassy
doesn't matter fine canada then
this is an active shooter situation
you're cleared for maximum engagement
maximum engagement what is this jurassic
park the ride
yep peralta in santiago you're the
assault team i'll be in the command
center scully i want you to do nothing
just stand next to me and say yes sarge
okay search come on man
and i am playing a character a
no-nonsense detective whose only goal is
to set this course record his name is
vic kovac he's an ex-navy seal who is
double-crossed and left for dead i don't
have time for his backstory sir
[Laughter]
backstory kick ass
captain
i'm just about to enter sprinkle city
this game has started to affect my work
i was three and four switch places
[Music]
[Laughter]
cupcake match i know what to do you ever
play quasi cupcakes i just got up to
sprinkle city oh my gosh what level are
you on captain holt sprinkle city
we have so much in common
no
you need to throw her phone away
yeah he's got another one
yes
beat the record
turn around
clear
he's got a drill it's good clear
[Music]
okay only three perps left
you might actually do this i like the
kovacs so much more than jake peralta
oh
i love how it always smells like fresh
paint here reminds me how often i moved
as a child oh
look out
come on
that was close there's pain in your hair
okay here goes i'm pissed at you oh no
you didn't invite me to your wedding it
hurt my feelings oh
vivian thought it might be weird to
invite you because i used to be i'll
consume by my passion and love for you
or whatever i understand
hey thanks for shooting that guy
hey
my pleasure
this was a human being you just killed
bill perp had a family
oh wow
[Laughter]
i'm going in
don't worry i have a plan on how to beat
them
give up what
trust me or don't i'm doing it anyway
nypd don't shoot
upside down
[Laughter]
drop the weapons all right all right my
fingers are off the triggers slowly put
them down in front of me yes he's doing
do
it
18 minutes 28 seconds you broke the
records
yeah
elderly lady
all right let's go drinks are on me oh
nice here we go now
oh no no teddy asked me to get dinner i
knew it maybe i could meet up with you
guys afterwards yeah
of course cool boobs
oops whatever
i hate that guy
i just talked to vivian i told her i
really want you to come to the wedding
and she said okay
thanks excited to go
also std stands for sexually transmitted
disease that is correct it is however
very expensive to reprint those cards so
we're leaning into
it oh
and congratulations to you captain on
beating your crazy cupcakes addiction
oh no i had to tell him it's my major
you helped me today so i'll give you a
pass on embarrassingly publicly thank
you
technology has evolved to the fact yeah
i don't know i think it's just bright
and stupid and fun
so far so
fun
[Laughter]
what do you think amy sees in teddy so
you do like her i'm just curious i guess
he's okay looking and he's a good cop
they're both kind of dorky about police
stuff also he set the course record but
that's nothing i broke it like 20
minutes later
you want to know why she went out with
him and not you yeah
because he actually asked her out
uh
what the hell is he talking about no i
don't think that's it thank you for
inviting me to your wedding yeah i'm
really happy you could come too because
i didn't think it was gonna happen
what do you mean well chuck told me you
were gonna be out of town that weekend
and then you know he just told me that
your plans changed
amy
check it out no way you won coolest kill
not even close it turns out anyone can
just buy themselves a children's karate
trophy smart
i wanted to ask you something of course
i was just wondering
are you wearing lipstick
yeah i'm going out with teddy again
no
it's not important i just had a question
about a work thing but have a great date
and we'll talk tomorrow yeah
okay
i'll help you with your work stuff jakey
perfect
i hate that guy
freaking teddy and his friendly
competent likable face guys a douche
douche checker where does he get off
this is a television show what
yeah it's a tv show believe it or not
john i know your
lack of
smartest
is
just makes you you just
dumb slow down when you speak
i'm sorry you can't keep up with my
intelligence but that is your problem
what i'm trying to communicate to the
audience
is that
characters are meant to live vicariously
through them
so yeah greg in real life total [ __ ]
when it comes to asking out women his
whole life
sucked at it really did
always sucked at it
peralta shouldn't
damn it
relatable but it upsets me i don't like
this teddy guy comes across like a dick
i don't care what anyone says
total d-bag not likable one second
typical just typical
what's so special what's special about
it it seems like a lot like nothing
another white guy just another white
bread
gooding boy scout boring personality
boring and he sucks at his job yeah also
beat it in
like 20 minutes yeah the rest of his
team probably carried him
freaking stupid there's literally
nothing about him that seemed unique
yeah not a lack of chemistry come on
yeah no can nothing hate that guy don't
get it don't get it at all
hate him
and then boyle
so many childish people here at the
priesthood [ __ ] man boyle lied yeah
clearly blamed it on vivian blaine on
his fiancee when really it was his own
insecurities his own worry you know why
he probably still kind of likes rosa
what
i don't know dude i bet that would that
would spell a lot of conflict down the
line uh you know most tv shows are not
built on conflict so it seems kind of
weird
however i think it totally applies to
the situation
i could see that i could i could maybe i
could maybe see that maybe see but like
boyle even like where does he get off
you know trying to tell peralta
about pursuing amy when he can't even be
a man and talk to rosa on the level you
know these people are all just children
children was the theme of this yeah holt
became a
child yeah that's what i mean childish
behavior but then look
the person who starts out the episode
most childish scully with the upside
down guns turns out to have the most
adult solution by the end that's what i
mean you know if you're an adult who
braces your embraces your uh braces your
childish side
boom
that's how you become an imaginative
creative adult but if you're an adult
who doesn't realize you're doing that
because you're just hating you're just
just a dummy you're just this is
stunning i'm eating it just a dumb ass
yeah don't deserve to lose your job if
you're that person that's i think they
should all be fired yeah should all be
fired from beginning and yeah this
episode like the show should just become
every week they get fired
yeah
and then we see how they're picking
themselves up and they get fired from
that place they can't be the first
people to do std right
probably not in real life i don't think
i've ever gotten an std for safe to date
i don't think i've ever gotten an std
but it's happened before i've got a lot
of saved dates recently but not an std
one i've gotten a lot of stds yes
rarely i'm invited to save the dates due
to my stds yeah they're like oh we can't
have uscd because you got stds you're
literally a walking std everywhere you
go
yeah you don't even have to like engage
in that in the intimate way with people
you can just give it to them just by
being often
people started wearing masks before the
pandemic due to the amount of stds i
have because they were afraid of
catching yes simply through interacting
with me
osmosis and breathing the same air
that's what happens i mean i'm already
completely compromised just being here
all the time and you probably have
several
you know working in a nuclear power
plant or something like that just like
the radiation constantly from your stds
but surprisingly gives off very
appealing pheromones yeah yeah it smells
like raspberries and coconut cream in
here that's what i mean not only is the
scent that good but the pheromones have
this absorb that's why i have so many
stds because people can't resist they
can't resist hence the amount of stds
due to the engagement i've had with the
amount of
women men
sometimes
alternate
there's everything under the sun
and they're all attracted to you
there's a problem
that's a real problem yeah
i'm like greg could you stop the orgy so
we could start shooting today maybe
and then you're like it's not up to me
buddy it's not up to me it's like i
could either handle it or i could be
distracted by it and it's really
distracting so you got to handle it i
get it i understand thank you you're
it's okay you know it's a unique
struggle oh totally but i can i see you
yeah see you get where i'm coming from
here
you know deserves some std who probably
has stds teddy he talked about the no
genitalia
dentals and how a man could run that
long without any genitals
that's the mark of the net like he's
probably someone who's been to a lot of
group meetings for those with highly
infectious stds
uh that are transferred just through the
atmosphere yeah uh that is a thing that
you are educated on in there because a
lot of us have been contemplating you
know cutting off our genitals in order
to help out and we have learned that you
can still perform at a highly
highly qualitative pace at your local la
fitness
if you don't have genitals you still run
on the treadmill for a long time oh yeah
and then it's even like more aerodynamic
you know you don't have the weight it's
awkward yeah really spatial disposition
yeah it's like it's you're streamlined
yeah oh definitely you could probably
beat a lot of people in sports now by
getting rid of the thing that allows you
to stream
which one was gonna break it
how far did we get it
six minutes not bad
[Laughter]
good episode it was a good
it was a good episode and uh i think
that uh yeah the action was cool and it
was really fun and i had a great time
plenty of alcohol real quick yeah
i'm so drunk
i'm so drunk right now i think i think
it was awesome and i'm rooting for
peralta
love these characters love spending time
with them every week love laughing along
with you what was your favorite part of
the episode leave your thoughts down
below hey subscribe to stds click that
notification bell hit that like button
if you have one and also hey let's do
j
t
j t
chose you today because you have an std
um several of them as a matter of fact
and so i was like who would be most apt
to shout out in this video today
obviously you as a matter of fact jt is
an acronym for
a form of an std
um
juicy transmitted
disease yep
terrible terrible situation but
there's a reason why they got one
because the man is
is absolutely
so attractive that he was just bound to
bound to get once so virile
give a guy that kind of look you're like
wow he's just mounted
mounting a truck
just dropped trowel and
hey man we were just talking about you
jt
what's up man yeah we're just shouting
you out making some stupid joke about
you having an std i'm so aroused
oh
i didn't realize you really you really
have one oh
oh
um
i can't call it back let me call it back
i was just informed that jt
uh
thanks for being part of our patreon
page jt
[Music]
you